à chartres pour en savoir plus sur le
travail des vitraux baptiste retrouve
kevin picole le maître verrier qui a
travaillé sur ceux de la cathédrale
alors combien d'heures de travail déjà
pour celui ci la lah pour un panneau
comme celui ci un panneau terminé on est
à peu près sûr une
une trentaine d'heures de travail
technique n'a pas évolué quasiment pas
vu depuis plus d'un an
donc nous on découpe donc le vert avec
cet outil là c'est une petite molette
qui en carbure de tungstène et là on
découpe en fait et la pression pour
qu'elle soit régulière c'est à dire
qu'il faut presque pas avoir le très
juste ça normalement ça suffit
première leçon de découpe pour baptiste
je me suis déjà coupé voilà donc ça
c'est le métier qui rentre
le professeur redevient élèves voilà
juste eu facile j'adore apprendre des
trucs c'est génial qu'est ce que c'est
ça alors c'est du plomb c'est du plomb
enfin c'est un alliage de plomb ça va
faire le tour c'est à fait du vitrail
qui est là
kevin élabore des vitraux contemporains
avec les mêmes gestes que les maîtres
verriers d'autrefois
là on va se lancer dans la soudure c'est
ça alors juste avant on va quand même
rabattre à rabat voilà là on va aplatir
ce qu'on appelle les ailes de plomb pour
la soudure baptiste utilise de la
stéarine issus de la graisse animale à
mélanger habilement avec les teints et
le plomb
voilà c'est bien 19h18 a bondi une fois
que la soudure et fait on va pouvoir
brosser le vitrail faut que ça c'est
pour un particulier
bon c'est vrai qu'on est dans une ville
chartres les vitraux oui forcément donc
les particuliers m
avoir une pièce donc nos cursus et bat
vraiment mille fois merci
kevin c'était vraiment intéressant de
découvrir ce métier a finalement chargé
d'histoire et ben justement l'histoire
c'est non seulement la grande comme on
l'a vu à la cathédrale mais aussi la
transmission d'un savoir comme tu le
fais ici
donc moi en tout cas c'était un plaisir
de vous recevoir
à l'atelier moi c'est un plaisir partagé
et nous on se retrouve une prochaine
fois dans une autre émission